vous êtes déjà fait interpeller vous
benjamin castaldi jamais quoi c'est vrai
c'est déjà vainqueurs folie est resté
coi d'histoire baja les a trop vite vous
avez allaité à nos téléspectateurs elle
et ronan c7 c'est mal mais on sait que
c'est mal mais dit le beaucoup trop vite
combien arrêté plus de 200 plus d'un an
c'est là qu'on sait que le tgv
l'histoire mais je roulais trop vite
alors mal et jean-michel racontez nous
il faisait la course avec 4 tgv sur l'a6
est flat avec une porsche je crois ça et
il est hélas rattrapé le tgv où il a
dénoté j'avais été très vite 87
il ya des voitures qui veulent le
remettre ce quelle voiture ça c'est ce
que j'ai fait et dire que je vais
produire ma voiture ce week-end sur la
tête de merckx est vrai beau servat non
ça va les retraits de permis qu'au début
j'étais 24 mois de retrait de permis
évidemment mais je 859 ah oui c'est
ouais bah non alors non pas sa confiance
alors c'est énorme c'est énorme je vous
le dis 900 euros mais je trouve que
c'est pas assez pour mettre plus mais
deux ans de retraite et remis le genre
moi mais j'aurais dû vous mettre plus
sérieusement sa mère de la maison c'est
mérité ça danse ça c'est mérité oui
alors moi j'étais une fois je reconnais
dans la voix vip et du coup j'ai déjà
relance dedans et je me fais arrêter à
part un motard dans la voie de bus oui
enfin bon we must have à l'ipp bave
c'est oui ces bus ou ou parfois mois et
du coup j'ai été dans la voix et oui je
suis pressé et elle m'a policier mort
d'un motard m'arrête je sais que ma vie
n'intéresse personne vous l'avais dit
aux donneurs mais ils me reconnaissent
si c'est 1 et donc il va peut-être et
moi je le reconnais je les ai vus sur
tmc
avant quand on travaille chez nous était
chez lui non et me dit c'est pas parce
que vous faites de la télé boudé droite
prenez votre bus et gilles mais vous
aussi vous faites de la télé ça vous
amuse autant que moi je l'ait reconnu
sur tmc
du coup pas petit papotage j'ai fait une
photo avec lui il était tout fier et
j'ai continué j'ai péché mignon
les reconnaît magnifique on a tellement
c'est ouf les motards souvent tu les as
vu danser vous avez le permis vous vous
vous êtes pas mieux ah oui j'étais sûr
et bon mois à papa scooter lui risque
pas de faire d'excès de vitesse
franchement à un scooter à crédit vous
avez acheté un scooter à crédit ouais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]